the government might say we're going to
fund some competitor of yours who might
be have a quite inferior product but
suddenly the inferior product blows them
out of the water because that's where
the money is hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Bob gray boys he's a senior research
analyst at the Mercatus Center at George
Mason University he writes a lot about
healthcare and he is particularly great
on talking about the need for increasing
the supply of healthcare Bob thanks for
talking to Reason glad to be here one of
the fascinating kind of blind spots of
Obamacare is that it you know it
definitely increases the demand for
health care it brings more people into
the insurance system and whatnot
it doesn't really do anything about the
supply side of growing the number of
healthcare providers or places you can
get it why is that a problem
well it's problem we've really for two
to three generations we've almost
completely ignored the supply side there
was this framing of the argument that
the most important thing on earth was
how many people had an insurance card in
their wallet and once I'd played that
the other side basically answered we can
mail out insurance cards better than you
can so we've had a debate only on sort
of one part of the scissors and can you
talk a little bit about like it does
insurance equal healthcare or good
health outcomes is that a clearly
established connection no insurance
doesn't equal care and care doesn't
equal outcomes we really should focus on
health so what are the what are the
quickest ways that we can grow the
supply of healthcare what are the types
of things that are standing in the way
of just having more healthcare widely
available I often quote John Cochrane
the University of Chicago who asked
what's the best thing we could do to
improve the supply of healthcare and the
outcomes and his answer was look for
every obstruction to the supply and get
rid of it so what are some of those well
there's a bunch of the federal level the
FDA is is a clogs the system slowly
leeches out drugs and devices the
Medicare reimbursement system is
probably the single biggest problem
weight but and that that keeps
care from happening even though danta
isn't that just a bill paying machine
that they just kick out checks every
time their ass it is well not every time
their ass but yes the built a machine
but essentially it says this qualifies
as health care and this doesn't we will
pay for this if we don't pay for it
don't do it
talk about certificate of need
requirements in various states there are
loads of state regulations in fact some
of the worst regulations are at the
state level certificate of need I live
in Virginia in Virginia if a hospital if
you want to open a new hospital you've
got a beg permission of the state
authorities who might very well be
sitting on the board of the big wheezing
old hospital in your town so it's if you
you you have to go and beg for approval
from people who may run hospitals you
would become essentially or at least one
one step removed and and not just open a
new hospital expand an existing one or
even just to buy a cat-scan machine to
put in your hospital really and then
what about you know I know Walmart in a
couple of other places are trying to
open up health clinics and their stores
or Urgent Care places where people can
drop in is that is that too hot is is it
being made harder than it should be well
it's certainly being made harder than it
should be at the same time that's a good
fix it's a partial fix there that it's
still it's a more efficient way of
distributing the stuff that's out there
it's not getting the stuff that's not
out there on the table well I talked a
little bit about that then so I you know
what's in the pipeline what are the big
innovations that might you know just
totally crack open you know this kind of
health care squeeze because at this
point you know everybody has to wait to
see a doctor you know you never know if
you're gonna get in stuff like that so
what what would revolutionize the supply
of healthcare we are in what a couple of
people have called a Cambrian explosion
of new technologies that are ready to
happen so for example 3d printed hands
I've got one sitting in my office a
prosthetic costs an fda-approved
prosthetic costs twenty five to eighty
thousand dollars the 3d printed ones
which worked quite well cost five to ten
dollars
but not none of our insurance will pay
for those and so on a certain level if
it's five to ten dollars you don't need
insurance right this is a really huge
workaround
absolutely absolutely however there are
other technologies coming on stream we
are on the verge of having for instance
3d printed organs hearts livers kidneys
whatever made of your own cells so
there's no need for a donor there is no
need for rejection
however the extreme caution extreme
caution within the FDA and within other
agencies and by the way within the
private sector within the medical
societies may be slowing these things
much more than they need to but at the
same time we've got the genomic
revolution it's now possible to create a
drug that is only good for Nick
Gillespie and a different one for me
even if we've got the same illness
however FDA trials take large groups 15
years and they're not going to get a
large sample of Nicholas bees what else
is coming on wearable telemetry or what
is telemetry what even sure wearable
telemetry so instead of going down to
the doctor to get your blood pressure
and your heart rate you wear something
that's giving a continuous and thereby
much more accurate read social media
have all sorts of medical applications
it's now easier for Google looking at
their searches to describe an ongoing
epidemic for instance than it is for the
CDC to figure what is is is this kind of
like with the copyright violations and
unauthorized downloads and whatnot where
this innovation is going to happen and
it's just a question is it going to
happen in our lifetimes or are we not
going to be able to see this and
technology will just leapfrog all of
this and things will be better at some
point I think they will I think they
will happen the question is as you say
will it happen in our lifetime I think a
more relevant question may be is it
going to have
the united states or are we going to
lose the technological edge because we
slow everything down this is not like
developing a billion dollar drug a lot
of these technologies require relatively
low capital investments and low amounts
of labor is this I mean is it ultimately
they're kind of up to individuals to
demand this and to create it on their
own in a way because we're obviously the
FDA is not responsive to individual
patients it's not even really into it's
not responding responsive to needs the
government tends not to be insurers or
not I mean they're hardly you know quick
moving I mean it doesn't really come
down to individuals kind of demanding
this and creating it on their own it
does though you know I've been traveling
the country meeting with innovators and
I mean some of them are just doing
absolutely dazzling things but just
about all of them have a common fear
which is it's gonna take me years to
develop this it's gonna cost a lot of
money I've got some backing and at the
stroke of a pen a regulator could say
can't do this and I'm out or at the same
time the government might say we're
going to fund some competitor of yours
who might be have a quite inferior
product but suddenly the inferior
product blows them out of the water
because that's where the money is yeah
alright well we'll leave it there when
do you think actually for a final
question when do you think we'll
actually start having a national
conversation about the supply of health
care rather than the demand for it well
I'll have a paper out in about a month
I'm hoping that's exactly when it starts
but and I'll just close with saying I'm
often asked what's you know how do we
get there and the answer first of all
you don't get there by coming up with a
big comprehensive bill and squabbling
over it like we did with the ACA I think
it's really going to be something like
World War 2 Pacific Theater warfare
where it's one island at a time and
that's where we get there at the state
level at the federal level and through
the medical societies and medical
schools which are also impendence yeah
do those cheap prosthetic the hands do
they motivate the middle finger to give
to the people that are holding back
medical innovation
have you been talking to somebody about
that not at all but we'll leave it there
Bob gray boys he's a senior research
fellow at the Mercatus Center at George
Mason University look for him at their
website murky distort Bob thanks very
much thanks a lot